il fait de la politique de façon
vraiment différente des autres et on
avait envie d'avoir votre point de vue
là dessus voici deux petits extraits du
rufin dans le texte ou plus exactement
dans l'image
d'abord voilà le rufin vitupérant c'est
un clash entre ce député est la
présidente de la commission des lois
présidente la république en marche voilà
ce que ça donne c'était le mardi 5 mars
mais vous savez la voie que je porte
aujourd'hui qui vous apparaît forte elle
n'est rien comparé à la voix qui a envie
de convient de faire entendre un centre
au nom de personnes dans le pays alors
habitués vous venez avec des tampons ils
venaient avec des boules quiès mais
laissez moi tranquille
laissez-moi leus harmonieux merci non
non non non non mais je referai non non
non alors monsieur rufin vous allez
baissé d'un ton vous avez quatre minutes
je pouvais lui sèment la mission
spéciale
on vient mature et dispose d'une voix
qui peut être largement supérieure à la
vôtre
on a quatre minutes ça s'est toujours
passé ainsi dans le respect de chacun et
comme le dit monsieur de courson
personne né sourd mais laissez moi ça je
crois que vous avez pour terminer mon
propos je vous remercie
et maintenant voici un autre exercice de
style de françois ruffin cette fois ci
dans un registre intimiste le député
sort ces jours ci un livre qui s'appelle
ce pays que tu ne connais pas c'est une
lettre ouverte à emmanuel macron et
voilà comment il se définit lui par
rapport à emmanuel macron il se trouve
qu'ils s'étaient tous les deux ans la
même école
amiens quand il était jeune séquence
émotion moi j'ai un sentiment de
médiocrité régulier en particulier
l'essence et jouer demande si je vais
m'en sortir un jour de
sentiment d'être nulle d'être une merde
ne pas trouver son chemin
où est ce qu'on va être valorisée qu'est
ce que est ce qu'il ya des gens qui vont
nous mfah tu vois je sais pas je pense
qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui traverse
cette phase là et il ya des gens qui
malheureusement il reste que je pense
que ça lui manque à emmanuel macron
christophe des vols pour 1 le professeur
de rhétorique que vous êtes c'est un
sujet d'observation formidable et encore
plus formidable j'agirai me shakespeare
yacé je voudrais une pièce de théâtre
sur les relations entre françois ruffin
et emmanuel macron c'est quelque chose
de gémellaire vous avez rappelé qu'ils
ont grandi à amiens dans le même lycée
des mêmes écoles privées d'ailleurs la
providence à la providence que ils sont
tous deux issus d'un milieu qui n'est
pas véritablement défavorisés ce qui
explique d'ailleurs peut-être chez eux
comme chez tous les enfants gâtés faut
bien le dire une facilité à la
transgression qui est peut-être plus
grande que dans les milieux populaires
et puis donc cette espèce de gémellité
de polémique avec ce ressentiment c'est
vraiment l'homme du ressentiment redit
aurait dit nietzsche à c'est vraiment
mais en même temps touchant là parce
qu'il vient de dire sur l'adolescence et
mon avis d'ailleurs ça fait ça a dû
toucher pas mal de gens mais qui
véritablement n'est pas dans un
comportement politique acceptable tout
simplement et j'ai d'ailleurs là en ce
jour des droits des femmes
bravo à olivia grégoire qui a vraiment
qu'il a remis à sa place j'ai écouté
tout l'extrait avec un talent et une
fermeté et je ne valoir connaissez pas
le rôle d'un élu de parler comme ça ce
n'est pas le rôle d'un élu je pense de
parler comme ça parce que
ne serait ce que parce que c'est un
comme autant pour les autres c'est aussi
ce que nous disions tout à l'heure il
est quand même le et pour un libéral
n'oublions jamais le respect de la
liberté d'autrui
et comme comme a dit très bien la
présidente de la commission
nous ne sommes pas sourds alors tout ça
n'est pas si grave en tout cas dans les
relations entre rufin et olivier gras
puisque entre temps ils se sont
réconciliés on vous passe à l'antenne un
instant ce clash comme si tout ça
c'était peut-être un peu que de la com
et c'est un autre point du du sujet mais
lorsque vous êtes fan parce que vous
appréciez la rhune fans
en tout cas moi son film merci patron
c'est un film que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant les causes qu'il défend
c'est des causes qui me sont chers je
trouve que les gens qui ne sont rien
sont des gens importants et donc de ce
point de vue rufin défend une certaine
partie des gens qui ne sont rien et ce
sont des français avec lesquels je me
sens tout à fait en empathie mais il
faut écouter ce qu'il disait avant que
olivia grégoire lui crie elle aussi
dessus
il parlait de choses très importantes
qui était la privatisation d'adé paix et
il le faisait
voilà aéroports de paris il le faisait
avec beaucoup de professionnalisme en
citant l'ensemble des sénateurs qui
s'était exprimée de droite comme de
gauche
enfin il y là il faisait vraiment une
démonstration extrêmement intéressante
de des raisons pour lesquelles aéroports
de paris ne devait absolument pas être
très fatigué et c'est vrai qu'il s'est
laissé emporter par ce qu'il disait
parce que je pense que c'est quelqu'un
de sincèrement passionnés pense que
c'est pas du tout quelqu'un qui qui
aspirent à faire une carrière au sens au
sens bassement carriériste je pense
qu'il est vraiment habitée par ce qu'il
ce qu'il croit on peut parfois ne pas
être d'accord il ya certaines dérives la
france a soumis ce que je ne partage pas
du tout mais je pense qu'il est sincère
dans son combat et la sincérité dans le
combat en politique
et particulièrement en ce moment je
trouve ça assez rare quand même donc
j'apprécierais fin de ce poignet alors
dans votre vote
chers internautes vous vous êtes plutôt
pas fan partant de cette phase pas très
bien construite 76 % répondent non à
cette question êtes vous fan de françois
ruffin et son franc parler en revanche
les commentaires sont assez assez
divers ou à vannes ou 10 pour avoir
observé françois ruffin lors des séances
de vote du parlement il est très présent
pour un député ce n'est pas commun le et
alors il défend les valeurs de la
république et son humanité me touche
beaucoup car elle est absente de la
politique présente alors michel lui
n'aime pas du tout dit je ne
l'apprécient pas car entre autres sont
parlé trop agressif r34 new deal confond
politique et spectacles dans le passé
les joutes à l'assemblée était tout
aussi cinglante mais beaucoup plus
intelligente préfet impose de vrais
problèmes et ne propose rien de positif
alors que nicole sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit je ne veux pas de ce côté de
l'échiquier mais rufin remonte très
souvent les vrais problèmes et appuie là
où ça fait mal
adrien matteau qu'est ce que vous pensez
du cac rufin c'est vrai qu'ils
pourraient et qui vise un peu la place
de mélenchon non je n'ai pas la réponse
mais pas que non de macron oui alors à
terme d'abord c'est vrai que c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui est vraiment c'est comme
vous le dites c'est un trublion mais
c'est un trublion sérieux parce que il a
une équipe autour de lui qui est très
soudée il rencontre des gens et
rencontres notamment des hauts
fonctionnaires
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a une certaine
indépendance et un électronique de la
france est soumise
jean luc mélenchon le traite de manière
assez alors on va on va faire le
parallèle entre macro et françois
hollande de manière assez voilà il est
pas très inquiète parce qu'il a
conscience de caractère d'électron libre
de de françois ruffin
mais c'est vrai qu'il semble se poser en
alternative à l'or sur le sur le fond
alors on n'a pas à être fan ou pas fan
de françois hollande quand on est
journaliste mais je souscris à ce que
dit barbara le faible c'est quelqu'un
qui est sincère
c'est quelqu'un qui est empathie qui
représente une forme de dignité
populaire et il a le souci de défendre
les
les gens d'en bas les gens ordinaires
c'est vrai que ben on aurait peut-être
pu passer la séquence en entier avec
olivier grégoire c'est vrai que quand
elle lui dit c'est un record business
c'est vrai qu'il ya un fossé entre la
france pour les cadres sup des start-up
heures et la france dé gilet jaune que
défend rufin avec sincérité
c'est pas une mise en scène artificielle
c'est quelqu'un qui est vraiment habitée
par là parce qu'il défend et vos
guillaume bernard à ce que vous êtes
sensible aux personnages ont une fin en
tout cas il est efficace il est certain
que il a acquis une visibilité par
rapport à mélenchon et une lisibilité de
son discours qui est quand même plus
clair encore que dans la sphère je
dirais des conflits entre
communautariste et républicains au sein
de la france a soumises
il n'a pas été toujours très je dirais
avec une ligne très claire et je crois
qu'il a peut-être surtout chercher je
dirais à préserver son indépendance et
sa visibilité plus que de prendre
vraiment position on l'attendait plutôt
du côté des républicains que des
communautaristes voilà bon mais il est
certain que il a cherché et je crois
qu'il a quand même plutôt réussi à
essayer d'incarner un populisme dit de
gauche
bon moi je ne crois pas qu'aujourd'hui
le populisme soit véritablement
susceptibles d'être de gauche parce que
dans le fond il
quand on parle de populisme on parle du
peuple et le peuple c'est un terme qui
peut renvoyer à deux choses soit des
catégories sociales soit au corps
politique
or il me semble qu'aujourd'hui la
question du peuple en tant que catégorie
sociale populaire est en fait liée est
intimement liée à la question du corps
politique et notamment la question de
l'identité la question de la pérennité
de ce corps politique donc il me semble
que à terme son populisme dit de gauche
et vous est en fait à un échec mais pour
autant il est certain qu'il a cherché à
essayer de développer ce créneau ce
créneau là et il a été sur la question
des gilets jaunes beaucoup plus efficace
beaucoup plus présent en contact avec le
terrain d'où sa visibilité et son
efficacité
quant à ce le fait que dans un débat
parlementaire
il hausse le ton ça me paraît la moindre
des choses qu'un parlementaire puisse
hausser le ton et porter la parole de
ceux qu'ils représentent je vous
rappelle que tous les députés nous
sommes dans le cas de la souveraineté
nationale papa dans le cadre d'un d'une
démocratie directe et donc françois
ruffin représente tout autant que ses
collègues la souveraineté nationale et
aucune raison de chercher à le faire
taire si en revanche on passait à une
démocratie directe effectivement avec un
mandat impératif il ne représenterait
que ses électeurs sur cette question
juste du populisme de gauche
rapidement c'est françois ruffin c'est
quelqu'un qui contrairement à beaucoup
de ses collègues de la france vise ne
maîtrise pas les penchants conservateur
que peuvent avoir les catégories
populaires ab-so-lu-ment à une volt
d'ecoute par rapport aux gens qui vont
être par exemple opposé à la pma ou un
mail pour tous et c'est quelque chose
qui lui est assez reproché par certains
au sein d'un front sans sommeil et d'où
d'ailleurs le fait qu'il refuse le front
républicain
voilà c'est s'affranchir des éléments de
langage de la france insoumise que
certains autres orateurs puisqu'il
s'appelle orateurs nous débite en
permanence sur toutes les chaînes info
est dans tout alors que lui justement il
tient un discours qui est à la fois dans
le corpus idéologique plus ou moins la
france a soumise mais avec la petite
touche rufin et c'est en ça que il est
très inquiétant à l'intérieur de la
france un solide pour jean luc mélenchon
est quand même un petit peu de bémol
parce que là vraiment sur la sincérité
sur attention il ya quand même aussi à
côté qui met toujours la ds c'est ce
côté justement bourgeois culpabiliser
qui veut faire trés peuple ça j'ai
toujours un petit peu de méfiance
vis-à-vis de ça et d'autre part alors
sur le côté rapport au patronat et
rapport aux intérêts matériels
excusez moi il ya eu dans le canard
enchaîné un article sur son journal nous
rappelle qu'il a joint la savane sakhir
qui passe son temps à promouvoir ce que
fait françois ruffin alors je veux bien
que mais c'est aussi une entreprise
politique qu'il faut pas quand même le
présenter comme comme le succès comme le
successeur de l'abbé pierre conditions
de point de vue d'internautes jorat nous
dit il est dans la démagogie permanente
point d'exclamation et
fou monsieur babineau rufin est un
populiste dans le mauvais sens du terme
et brownie tôt le bon côté de rufin ce
qui pose parfois de bonnes questions
même sous une forme critiquable par
contre niveau solution c'est autre chose
il nous reste quelques minutes pour que
je vous montre un extrait du grand débat
d'hier c'est le grand débat régional
public que on organise régulièrement
pour parler directement avec les
citoyens et hier il était à
gréoux-les-bains jolie localités de la
région provence alpes côte